[Music]
one of the issues we haven't Gove into
too deeply around here is gun control
the contentious often venomous debate
about guns has been part of some of the
conversations we've had here on the
Rubin report especially when talking
about limited government constitutional
authority states rights and even freedom
of speech but it rarely has been the
focus of those conversations itself
interestingly gun control is one of the
issues that I get the most emails about
with people usually asking me my
personal feelings about the Second
Amendment and whether I believe in a
right to bear arms you're not going to
believe this but I do think that there's
a same middle ground that we can find in
the gun discussion that falls somewhere
between everyone should own a bazooka
and nobody should be able to have a
handgun first of all very clearly
without reservation I am a supporter of
the Second Amendment the Second
Amendment specifically states quote a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State the
right of the people to keep and bear
Arms shall not be infringed end quote
this is interesting wording because it
guarantees the right of a citizen to
protect themselves from both other
citizens and the state itself by having
the ability to own a gun but guaranteed
a life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness which is enshrined in the
Declaration of Independence isn't only
for the government to ensure for you
actually it's quite the reverse it's
incumbent on you to protect your life
your liberty and your pursuit of
happiness even from the government if
need be in many ways this is the essence
of individualism while the state and the
government are an important facilitator
of our rights it's ultimately up to us
the individual to make sure we are truly
protected from people and governments
who would take those rights away as I
often say however two things can be true
at once while having a populace that can
defend itself is important at the same
time there really is little doubt to me
that we have a gun problem in America
whether we're talking about school
shootings which happen all too often or
assassinations of police officers has
happened in Dallas last year there can
be no doubt that the gun is the weapon
of choice when someone wants to
indiscriminately kill as many people
as possible I should pause and separate
mass shootings from terrorism
specifically where terrorists usually
use some sort of explosive to kill as
many people as possible although
recently we've seen guns knives and even
cars and trucks thrown into the mix and
it's also important to remember that the
weapon itself doesn't make the
distinction between a criminal act or
terrorism
it's the ideology behind the act that
does that the fact that there are many
ways to kill people though does bring up
an interesting idea about guns if I had
an assault rifle or any other gun I
wouldn't go into a school or church or
anywhere else and randomly kill people
likewise I've got some pretty great
kitchen knives right down the hallway
here and I don't go into mosques or
temples and stab anyone this shows that
the gun itself is just the tool and the
issue around gun control is much deeper
we should be having an honest
conversation about issues like mental
health the overuse and side effects of
prescription drugs the insidious nature
of evil ideologies the access to guns
that mentally unstable people have and
much more
unfortunately we only seem to have these
conversations at the worst possible
times usually right after another
shooting this gets the anti-gun crowd in
a frenzy to take away all guns and it
gets the pro-gun crowd to think that the
government is going to come to their
house and take away their guns don't
believe me well just check how gun sales
skyrocketed under President Obama but
have now dipped under President Trump
all of these issues are just the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to guns I
think that there are good people on both
sides of the debate who just see a
different solution partly because they
are seeing a different problem in the
first place some see this truly as a
problem with guns themselves while some
see this as a larger societal problem
with mental health but perhaps just
perhaps there's merit to both arguments
joining me today to unpack this highly
charged discussion is Antonia Okafor
Antonia is a Second Amendment
advocate who spends most of her energy
pushing for legislation to allow women
to carry guns on college campuses as a
young black conservative she found
herself on the outside of what the
mainstream says someone who looks like
her should
Eve will talk about her political
evolution from an obama voter to a trump
supporter and why she thinks that a
woman's right to defend herself by
herself
is so important without the reactionary
hysteria were usually caught up in when
discussing guns can the two of us find
some common ground well there's only one
way to find out
[Music]
you